[Music]
dammit Josephine about washing louder
which brother is it 9:00 p.m. Eastern
always day there's only like free she is
the sunrise in the east of course I
watch it later with grinder you know I
never miss it
you're obsessed Colton it's not healthy
hell would you know about health miss
forklift with teeth just a stupid Shoko
they don't care about you
jimmy'll over that Oh you back to life
straight from the pit row and you know
it take a look right there boom from
Africa sound guy with a verified chip
more don't want here anymore - bullsh
blast you know it's not a real sound guy
it's just a character he plays do you
know it's that kind of stupid they
showed you telling her you are Josephine
he is a legitimate qualified sound
technician from a trade school he's
cello damper working with sound related
appliances your fingers were too fat to
operate a TriCaster maybe you can try it
who wants to lie you know better to work
that Jarrod's not even gay I've had it
with your lives Josephine in back of me
say when I'm quoting scripture from our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
it means you put down your show [ __ ]
every once in a while for a hot minute
you know better
[Music]
three million subscribers 100 million
views a month here you can sit back in
that wedding dress
[Music]
what you know I'm trying to watch my
grammar I bought this mobile watch daily
you know won't get my money learn I do
it after knocking dared faces your story
on rubra want to put them titties a good
news man you know it's what you were
made to do Josephine bet your domain I
wish I could help you with our plans
when it's on providing victims outfit
but you know we're always do
[Music]
so what what you think you think they're
doing that that's like a real set you
think that's one of them green screen
being this year I'll take it sound
spaceship would you think that Roy it's
got all that technology and whatnot and
can those dudes have have that crowd has
got a spaceship man you know it right
not everyone had more than a rotary
phone is an intergalactic what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you I didn't want to say
it call me your compressor missed pitch
him yes they got a [ __ ] spaceship I
know it I'm not being negative I'm just
being real bottles already been bolted
down you don't think they're bottles on
space you don't think they'd they'd
housing contain don't you read don't
forty think reading you think range for
Ridley Scott alien films don't you dream
participated Oh news they're watching
louder with Crowder I thought it was
only supposed to be four to five minutes
dammit Josephine I already told you
that's on weekdays when it's commercial
free it's Thursday it's just livestream
it's extended I don't know why you've
acted so much it's not even real news
dammit Josephine I already done told you
it's a combination of relevant news and
topics of the day in a package that I
find entertaining and palatable to
assimilate at reasonable price and it
helps me unwind so this is you relax
well I was until you got my back
Josephine now if you shut that
ever-expanding cosmos of a hole you call
a mouth I can get back to it you know
it's news nope
but news every time you took up stuff
bad word problem now I not only time let
me mad Josephine and then don't work and
I ain't gonna work thank you no you know
maybe Josephine why you got to do that
why you gotta push me you've never
checked me off just make you feel good
about yourself
Rebecca femto I got yourself to push my
buttons just joking
I already done told you Joseph it's not
funny
these guys are legit I wouldn't go to
Golden Corral if you were the last woman
on earth and my life depended on it not
over that last time you when you're
looking at a morning poster you up on
their wall
[Music]
bar there behind cries you'd never use
that [ __ ] buta for what I don't know
summary net heat strikes was like a
teetotaler some [ __ ] you know yes guys
like mom queers is on shape like he's
got that look looks like I know I don't
drink 20 beers of you man I'm like then
go jump rope with my [ __ ] queer
friends yeah I know but you know thing
is you can have both that's a problem
you understand you just got it you can
drink all the beer you want you just got
a lot of furnace the next day that burns
it up
it's called circuit training you'll try
that [ __ ] circuit training I can tell
you didn't try no I'm a uncle's an
electrician you don't think I know about
[ __ ] circuit training it is a complex
with compound movements that uses large
muscle groups are those my jorts
training theater
[Music]
oh are you watching that louder with
Crowder again is it 9:00 p.m. Eastern on
a weekday then of course I'm watching
leather banjos freedom a damn folk Club
member why can't you get back you just
pay full price
I did pay full price of $69 annually for
daily content as a student Josephine
you're not even a student Jamie won't
understand my old my I got my GED I
studied culinary arts and Bridgetown
that's why you I wouldn't even finish
I also ever bring fountain tempo karate
which is an arch something you don't
know Wow animal [ __ ] Phoenix I signed
up for the Mary wasted man you know I
hate spam
[Music]
[Applause]
and then push the beds together no what
are you gonna do stupid thing like that
cuddle go home get open bed next you
with them cold freak thanks your lack of
circulation from your varicose veins
you're out of your mind quick good bond
we go to be I'm working on them day I'm
trying to on one with my mom come on
smiling prouder
you can been arrested that's why I'm
stressed thank you for asking Josephine
I hope I clarified that you haven't work
one minute today told I gotta check
midnight that's right I'm on disability
for the pain I feel every damn day hey
my plantar fasciitis and [ __ ] when I'm
gonna check me burn you so is that why
you only pay sixty man annually from
that class I pay fifty nine for student
discount because of a veteran Josephine
you don't respect that you never have
their just bring you know that I wanted
to go to Iraq I'm flat funny you know
I'm went through the death might have a
better first yachties he still could
have done the Air Force I didn't wanna
be an Air Force Josephine
[Music]
go on crowd of get young who's this uh
who's his queer fell on the piano
Tammy Roy that's Owen Benjamin he's a
trained musician and comedian I don't
like him
Yankee [ __ ] you better watch
yourself Roy that man is a classically
professionally trained pianist I gotta
great Josephine I told you one credit
short before the baby so that's new for
you me just me
you ain't got no certification I went
through the process required to become a
certified Marion you just spotted on the
Internet Debbie Josephine I'm an
ordained minister doing it the work of
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ blessed
feeling I don't know do I deal in the
currency of lost souls Josephine and his
license is suspended would you shut the
[ __ ] up Roy
[Music]
[Music]
it doesn't mean I'm watching morning
grounders it comes my annual month club
membership and you know mo get my
money's worth
come on back to bed keep bringing about
sugar plums and Paula Deen recipes are
some sheep that's with that Courtney
scoffs no I know you know the market
Josephine not get a chair just smoked
her an armless of much even though she
can spoil a dump-truckin has ass that
what you want
is that a trick question I don't know I
responded a [ __ ] dumb you're a real big
woman just kind of chick still has both
her legs and no diabetes don't mean
she's dr. Joseph ain't baby way when the
baby's in middle school Josephine and so
boy he's just golden corral and aversion
to push up stop blaming it on the boy
you better hope he doesn't go cows
otherwise you lose your excuse for that
postpartum depression
[Music]
they think I'm not gay gentleman I miss
that one but we're gonna sing not gay
that mean is dude roll it Gucci what
what you get out they don't go home
don't ya beer your place now ran out I'm
just texting my crease tones I get back
you're off my dial-up won't stream HD
bro you know that damn it roll just take
my take my hotspot use that for a knife
by the time I get hooked up I might as
well stay and watch morning grinders for
eight hours so what's cool of us
don't push me off right
[Music]
you know I am Josephine demo I even got
asked that job to me like when you ask
you a question you already know the
answer to that's some passive aggressive
bullsh
it's not the UH nature Napper from
washalot affair you know i do a woman
every day every damn day
[Music]
there are days Josefina just made me
make the damn punchline I can't even
have any time to myself
oh it's 45 minutes every day - even for
money issues of the day
well watching advantage that keeps me
entertained but you would have to ruin
it but you want to watch your wife's why
don't work on a free woman on the corner
i'm fortunate damn couch whatever
happened is something dark night pounds
no what actually yeah I'm a [ __ ] okay
where I want
[Music]
she wrote that's what I'm talking about
it's not all photoshop and dick jokes if
you pay attention they really go to
great lengths to source their material
you could learn some [ __ ] I mean about
real cheap yeah you know that makes a
lot of sense I mean economically the
flat tax still has higher income earners
paying more in total taxes but the
percentage remains unchanged
which seemingly would be a more fair
means of distribution not to mention the
policies of feckless a monetary
inflation do you care what below the
poverty lines its birth canal
[Music]
there's a non-commissioned on weekday
stop asking stupid questions Josephine
and it doesn't mean you know where
Gessler she did not mention by lwc time
cuz you know it sets me off for only
$6.99 and on annually I get access to
loan prouder every damn day please
moaning riders bus the entire coz light
up English most beautiful of everything
handy smooth I'm a part of something
why can't you understand that and what
comes in case they rerun my episode and
I've been using as evidencing an appeal
[Music]
hey did you enjoy this video here's the
thing you wrote you're here this is the
end of it so we don't care because you
already watched it but if you really
didn't like it and you want to justify
it leave a comment below telling us why
you didn't like the video and if you
liked us let us know and subscribe to
the channel because that lets the
overlords at YouTube know that you know
what you're alright